but i think that what you're saying
right now this this this race war
that that the left is is fully behind it
and really wants to happen and all of
this idea of race and all this stuff
you have to understand that these people
are freaking
out they are terrified
that black americans are really starting
to see past their game when you look at
a millennial like me
um i have lived through a little bit of
this and i used to be on the left and
i've
made no bones about that but it just
gets to the point where
you've seen this all before
remember all the way back when to like
february when
we were pre-pandemic and we were having
those democratic debates do you remember
that
time of life oh my god it seems like a
million years ago at this point
so there was one of the debates when the
democrats were all going on and on
bernie and elizabeth and the whole crew
about how racist america was and and i
tweeted out
something to the effect of i said you
know i think it sounds crazy but trump's
going to get 30
of the black vote and they know it and
that's why they're freaking out because
before the pandemic
we know that black unemployment was at
an all-time low there was that crazy
moment at the state of the union where
he
he actually trump actually says that and
you watch the members of the
congressional black caucus
sit there like this as if as if this is
a problem i thought that's why they have
their caucus because we want people to
be prosperous and all that
um then we have now these months of
of race stuff um
what what do you think is going to
happen which way do you think
the the black vote is is gonna break at
the end of all this
well look i i think that pre-pandemic
honestly things were going so well for
for everybody
um if you were asking that question
pre-plan pandemic
i would have said oh yeah you know 30 40
whatever
you know that that was probably a little
high even before pretty pandemic
but i think that what you're saying
right now this this this race war
that that the left is is fully behind it
and really wants to happen and all of
this idea brace and all this stuff
you have to understand that these people
are freaking
out they are terrified
that black americans are really starting
to see past their game when you look at
a millennial like me
um i have lived through a little bit of
this and i used to be on the left and
i've
made no bones about that but it just
gets to the point where
you've seen this all before so you've
seen this story play out
over and over and over again so you get
to the point where you're like me and
you're post 30
and you're just looking at this stuff
and then you start saying wait a minute
and you start thinking differently
and then you you amass a platform where
people actually start listening to your
thoughts and there are people like me
and and god there's so many people out
there there's the me and the candace and
brandon tatum and
there's more than i can count right now
which is great which is a good thing
and that freaks the left out
because they can only control the the
black people that they've
ushered into positions of power in in
their sort of media
uh uh control groups right so the cnns
and the msnbc's of the world
but there's a lot of conversation that
is happening with us
and i will tell you um dave my social
media when all of these rights and all
this stuff started happening
exploded and when i tell you the
following
in all platforms just completely
exploded and it tells me
that people are hungry for a different
perspective so back to the black vote
i think we're looking at somewhere
between and to be completely honest and
100 real
i think we're looking at somewhere
between 12 and 15
and even if we get to 12 that's a
33 jump from from 2016
and if you get to 15 and 16 percent that
is
double all right what he did in in 2016
and democrats cannot win national
elections without
upwards of 90 of the african-american
vote they know this this is why they did
not win
in um 2016 because black people just
stayed home because they didn't want to
vote for hillary because
of a lot of different reasons and yet
they do the same thing they they
trot out another deeply unpopular
super establishment candidate that's
been around for
forever and say that this is gonna be
our change candidate so they make these
same mistakes over and over and over
again
the guy who's gonna change all of the
systemic racism is the guy that was in
the senate for like 30 years and was
vice president for eight years
this time he's gonna do it right it's
incredible
yeah this time he's gonna do the right
and it's the same guy that didn't want
um
integration in schools because he said
that it would turn schools into a quote
racial jungle yes joe biden said that
look it up
yeah what a what a weird thing do you do
you sense the gays are going to have a
similar crack
they're the gays oh the gays
the gays the gays um i i try my best
with the gays i honestly
really don't know i you can only okay so
you can only judge by
the following that you get and you can
judge by the dms and
and the emails and stuff that i get but
also i'm in
in florida right now the gays are
generally generally more conservative
leaning
i think that there is a subset and there
always has been
of gays and lesbians that are working
and law abiding citizens and they look
at some of this stuff and it
it just doesn't jive with you know uh
and i hope and
and i pray that the gays wake up i think
that a lot of them privately
are not into the cult stuff i think that
a lot of them
privately either don't vote for for
liberals or
or possibly even vote for republicans
possibly even vote for trump
but they would never dare say it
because they would never want to be
excommunicated like i said
which is what happened to you and i so
yeah i think we talked about this
last time but i honestly can't remember
the closet thing you know coming out as
a gay person versus coming out as
conservative or on the right or or
basically anything non-woke
at this point um which was harder for
you
it was so when you come out as gay
nowadays right you know you everybody
loves it and it's so accepting and
it's all good and it's whatever coming
out as conservative it was one of the
most
disruptive life events i've ever had in
my life
and and you're talking about somebody
you're talking to somebody that's been
to war right
so coming out literally yeah literally
literally been to war so coming as
conservative was such a disruptive life
event and i talked about this a little
bit
um losing all your friends um having
some family members say what what are
you doing people that were at
my wedding no longer talk to me
all right um the the best man at my
wedding no longer talks to me so it's
just
it's a very disruptive event so if i had
to say which one was harder for me it
was coming out as conservative
because you're coming out as gay people
are just like oh okay well you know
sometimes there's a problem with that
um most times there's not in 2020 but
when you come out as a conservative
this this stigma that is thrown on your
shoulders
is that you are based you are basically
hitler
you are basically supporting the worst
most
racist xenophobic homophobic
the worst of humanity as as i was called
on
social media um and so that is very
disruptive and
you have to have a very strong sense of
self
to come out of it on the other side
that's why i so openly share my story
that people get fired from their jobs
people i it was the most heartbreaking
thing
um one of my followers on facebook
reached out to me and her two grown
adult children
called her a racist nazi and completely
cut her
out of their lives and those stories
make me
so sad if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell